il est 10h à la maison à maria do coeur
de la forêt de port royal
une trentaine de chasseurs écoutent les
consignes de sécurité des déplacements
vécu même sur la propriété se font avec
les arbres dans les mousses tout
démonter gilet orange comme d'hab' el
mirador des outils utilisés pour la
sécurité de tous
on prend nos mirador pas ce que veut que
ces forêts périurbaines
on a obligation d'installer des miradors
donc chaque post et sera sur un mirador
après l'installation des miradors la
chasse peut commencer
un quota réglementaire de 13 chevreuil
est fixé pour le sanglier c'est illimité
les chasseurs sur les miradors attendent
les animaux les autres vont les traquer
ensuite on va traquer tous ensemble on
va sera aligné sur le chemin et on va
repousser directement sur les poster qui
sont là à peu près 1 km la regarde un
chevreuil qui va sauter la ligne voilà
ça permet la halle annonce ça permet de
prévenir pour les poster qui lie à un
chevreuil qui est sorti de la traque
regarde cendrier 6e sangliers tentent de
se cacher d'autres tracker ont repéré
une compagnie la chasse se poursuit dans
une autre partie de la forêt et cette
fois-ci l'annnonce du sanglier mort
retentir le surveiller à charge et quand
même
les chiens et donc les deux tracker vu
que je survis a été offert mme olivier
avec laurent bon bah ils ont tiré là
dans les ronces il était acculé avec un
premier sanglier abattu la chasse n'est
pas terminée la battue continue tout au
long de la journée